hi in this video we'll talk about
swi/snf nucleosome remodeling complex
and how does it work and what its
implication in health and diseases so
swi/snf stands for switch and sucrose
non fermentable this nucleosome
remodeling complex was discovered in
East in a genetic screen which was not
aim to identify this kind of nucleosome
remodeling complex but it was aimed to
identify mutants which are defective in
mating type switching or sucrose
fermenting capability and thereby mating
type switching stands for sweet SWI and
the sucrose non fermenting stands for s
NF and few years later these complex was
purified now the purified swi/snf
complex when added to a chromatin in
vitro it has been seen that it can
change the configuration of the
chromatin and it can change the
compaction and accessibility of this
chromatin that leads to an indication
that this kind of complex might be super
important in terms of changing the
chromatin architecture now we know that
this particular complex is super
important in East for mating type
switching in mating type switching there
are two types two mating types one is
alpha one is a and this mating type
switching requires a specific in nucleus
known as H o endo nucleus now h o in the
nucleus is a protein so it would be
transcribed by a gene which is called
the H Oh gene now the H or gene body has
several nucleosomes and the DNA which is
coding for this h OG aho protein would
be wrapped around histones or histone
course so something need to loosen these
DNA in order to get the access to the
gene body and get it transcribed only
when it is transcribed and translated
then the h of protein would be
produced and the mating type switching
can happen in this context is WI s NF
nucleosome remodeling complex takes
important role and let us review that
what type of role does it play
so this imagine this is the h OG no body
and the rate marking here denotes the
transcription start site now the
polymerase cannot get the access to the
transcription start site because that
portion is tightly wrapped around the
histone core it is totally inaccessible
now this swi/snf complex is recruited
near that region and it allowed and it
slides the nucleosome such that the
transcription start site is now free and
accessible to the RNA polymerase and
once it is accessible it can now move
along the gene body and transcribing the
h or chain now let us review the
mechanisms by which the swi/snf complex
can work the first thing the swi/snf
complex can do is change the nucleosome
spacing so the inter nucleosomal space
has very deep implication in terms of
gene expression let's say after sliding
the his histone course in a certain
manner certain regions are now
accessible to transcription factors or
let's say polymerases so that give rise
to change in gene expression profile
other than that the swi/snf complex can
lead to a fiction of histone in a
certain region as a result of histone a
friction from this particular region
shown here there could be a accessible
site where a transcription factor or RNA
polymerase can find and this lead to
change in gene expression profile now
his wasn F complex can also replace his
stone in a nucleosome to a histone
variant which might has implication in
terms of packing and ultimately
is important for gene expression now in
human in east in Drosophila this swi/snf
complex its structure its function is
pretty much conserved now let us look at
the domain structure of the swi/snf
complex in order to understand its
functionality so it has its atps domain
which is so important
the ATPase domain hydrolyze ATP and
these big complexes which are at least
having eight to eleven subunits requires
ATP hydrolysis in order to perform a
change at a chromatin level now changing
a chromatin landscape is not easy it
requires a lot of energy and
thermodynamically it is pretty
complicated other than that these
nucleosome remodelling complex has a
bromo or a chroma domain i mean which is
which make it capable to recognize
acetylated or methylated histones now in
human this swi/snf complex is known as
bath complex or pee bath complex in bath
purim or PRG one is the atps domain
whereas bromo domain is also present in
this particular bath complex HSA is a
domain which allowed this bath complex
to interact with acting bath 155 and
bath 170 regulates the stability of
these bath complex and has implication
in gene expression now bath complex has
different type of functions it is
involved in de neurogenesis and
modulating spine density it was found to
be involved in learning and memory
now bath complex help to maintain the
neuronal progenitors at a stem cell
state at a stem state now other than
that it also regulates the proliferation
versus differentiation balance in early
brain development stages not only that
in many cases many cancers like breast
cancer colon cancer the gene mutations
which are frequently occurred involves
the bath complex genes now the genes
which give rise to bath complex are
heavily
mutated in several cancers this implies
that the functionality of bath complex
and bath complex mediated nucleosome
remodeling or changing in chromatin
structure is very important in terms of
development and diseases so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe thank you